there are more than half a million
children
at risk of serious harm across the uk
and it's often a race against time to
protect them
i need to do that section 47 today
this is the biggest social work
department in britain
part of kent county council and they're
seeing a sharp
rise in cases since school children
returned to their classrooms
they've had a couple of weeks to settle
back into the routine of school
and and now you know we know that
they're going to start
telling teachers what's happened during
lockdown we've been given access to the
work
that this team does to understand the
impact that lockdown has had on families
and especially children at one point he
was stood on the edge of a cliff
but a family friend pulled him back
they're talking about a lack of bedding
they're talking about there being no
food in the cupboards they're talking
about
drug paraphernalia and white powder
we've had a lot of incidents where
children are reporting that they've been
hurt
where they've witnessed domestic abuse
between their mum and their mum and the
dad so it makes us
worry about what children have
experienced and what they've endured
during lockdown
it's what we anticipated and it's
certainly come to the fore this week yes
absolutely
busy to find out more we've carried out
a poll of social workers
65 said referrals have gone up
compared to the same time last year and
of
all the issues they face a fifth pointed
to one
area in particular abuse in the home
social worker miles o'keefe is heading
to a local primary school to meet an 11
year old boy
who says a play fight with his
stepfather turned violent
but there's more to this story than
meets the eye
so my name's miles okay and i'm a social
worker
we've changed the young boy's name and
his voice to protect his identity
and then out of the blue noah reveals
what's really on his mind
[Music]
[Music]
something
and you know what i can see why you
might think that
because that's the experience that
you've had recently isn't it it's not
been very nice
noah's mum is asked to attend school for
a chat about the domestic violence her
son has spoken about
he kind of went off into a little bit of
a tangent
and the tangent he went off into was
around very much around
your situation about eight nine months
ago
uh one of my exes injured me quite a lot
i was very bruised
they didn't know anything about it um
but obviously certain things have been
heard at some point and he
he knows where the bruises came from he
does do you accept what he's saying
about the
past and other relationships and what
he's been
because i think this is his first cry
for help
social workers have told us that
lockdown for children like noah
means not being able to speak out about
their experiences
i got the sense that rather than be
freaked out by your involvement actually
mum
saw it was quite relieved by what was
being said and
by you being there and talking about it
all i think he's
associated all of those those
difficulties and challenging times of
his life
into one particular incident
the incident with the with his
stepfather
this is just one case among thousands
kept hidden by lockdown
only now emerging nick martin sky news
kent